that's good all right cool so yes I was
asked to give this presentation on the
foundations of deep learning which is
mostly going over basic feed-forward
neural networks and motivating a little
bit deep learning and some of the more
recent developments and and some of the
topics that you'll see across the next
two days so I as Andrew mentioned I have
just an hour so I'm gonna go fairly
quickly on a lot of these things which I
think will mostly be fine if you're
familiar enough with some machine
learning and a little bit about neural
nets but if you'd like to go into some
of the more specific details you can go
check out my online lectures on YouTube
it's now taught by a much younger
version of myself and so just search for
you go to a shell and I am NOT the guy
doing a bunch of skateboarding and the
geek teaching about neural nets so go
check those out if you want more details
but so well I'll cover today is I'll
start with just describing and laying
out the notation on feverel neural
networks that is models that take an
input vector X that might be an image or
some text and produces an output f of X
so I'll just describe for propagation
and the different types of units and the
type of functions we can represent with
those and then I'll talk about how we
actually train neural nets describing
things like loss functions back
propagation that allows us to get a
gradient for training with stochastic
gradient descent and mention a few
tricks of the trade so some of the
things we do in practice to successfully
Train neural nets and then I'll end by
talking about some developments that are
specifically useful in the context of
deep learning that is neural networks
with several hidden layers that came out
you know at the very after the beginning
of deep learning say in 2006 that is
things like drop out batch normalization
and if I have some time unsupervised
pre-training so let's get started and
just talk about assuming we have some
neural network how do they actually
functions how do they make predictions
so let me lay down the notation so a
multi-layer neural feed-forward neural
network is a model that takes as input
some vector
X which I'm representing here with a
different note for each of the
dimensions in my input vector so each
dimension is essentially a unit in that
neural network and then it eventually
produces at its output layer a an output
and we'll focus on classification mostly
so you have multiple units here and each
unit would correspond to one of the
potential classes in which we would want
to classify our input so if we're
identifying digits in handwritten
character images and so we're focusing
on digits you'd have ten digits or you
would have sort of zero from zero to
nine so you'd have ten output units and
to produce an output the neural net will
go through a series of hidden layers and
those will be essentially the components
that introduce non-linearity that allows
us to capture and perform very
sophisticated types of classification
functions so if we have L hidden layers
the way we compute all the layers in our
neural net is as follows we first start
by computing what I'm going to call a
pre activation I'm going to note that a
and imma go I'm going to index the
layers by K so a K is just the pre
activation at layer K and that is only
simply going to be a linear
transformation of the previous layer so
I'm going to note HK as the activation
and the layer and by default I'll assume
that layer zero is going to be the input
and so using that notation the pre
activation at layer K is going to
correspond to taking the activation at
the previous layer K minus one
multiplying it by a matrix WK those are
the parameters of the layer those
essentially corresponds to the
connections between the units between
adjacent layers and I'm going to add a
bias vector that's another parameter in
my layer so that gives me the pre
activation and then next I'm going to
get a hidden layer activation by
applying an activation function this
will introduce some non-linearity in the
model so I'm going to call that function
G and we'll go over a few choices we
have four common choices for the
activation function and so I do this
from
layer 1 to layer L and when it comes to
the output layer I'll also compute a pre
activation by performing a linear
transformation but then I'll usually
apply a different activation function
depending on the problem I'm trying to
solve so having said that let's go to
some of the choices for the activation
function so some of the activation
functions you'll see one common one is
this sigmoid activation function it's
this function here it's just 1 divided
by 1 plus the exponential of minus the
pre activation the shape of this
function you can focus on that is this
here it takes the pre activation which
can vary from minus infinity to plus
infinite and it squashes this between 0
& 1 so it's bounded by below and above
below by 0 and above by 1 okay so it's a
it's a function that saturates if you
have very large or very large magnitude
positive or negative pre activations
another common choice is the hyperbolic
tangent or tange activation function on
this picture here so squash is
everything but instead of being between
0 & 1 s between minus 1 and 1 and 1
that's become quite popular in neural
nets is what's known as the rectified
linear activation function or in papers
you will see the relative unit that
refers to the use of this activation
function so this one is different from
the others in that it's not bounded
above but it is bounded below and it's
actually it will output zeros exactly if
the pre activation is negative so those
are the choices of activation functions
for the hidden layers and for the output
layer if we're performing classification
as I said in the our output layer we
will have as many units as there are
classes in which an input could belong
and what we'd like is potentially and
what we often do is interpret each units
activation as the probability according
to the neural network that the input
belongs to the corresponding class that
it's labeled Y is the corresponding
class C so C would be like the index of
that you
in the output layer so we need an
activation function that produces
probabilities produces a multinomial
distribution over all the different
classes and the activation function we
use for that is known as the softmax
activation function it is simply as
follows you take your pre activations
and you exponentiate them so that's
going to give us positive numbers and
then we divide each of the exponentiated
pre activations by the sum of all the PD
exponentiated pre activations so because
I'm normalizing this way it means that
all my values in my output layer are
going to sum to 1 and they're positive
because I took the exponential so I can
interpret that as a multinomial
distribution over the choice of all the
SI different classes ok so that's what
I'll use as the activation function at
the output layer and and now beyond the
math in terms of conceptually and also
in the way we're going to program neural
networks often we will do is that all
these different operations the linear
transformations the different types of
activation functions will essentially
implement all of them as an object and
object that take arguments and the
arguments would essentially be what
other things are being combined to
produce the next value so for instance
we would have an object that might
correspond to the computation of pre
activation which would take as argument
what is the weight matrix and the bias
vector for that layer and take some
layer to transform and that would this
object we sort of compute its value by
applying the linear activation the
linear transformation and then we might
have objects that correspond the
specific you know activation functions
or like a sigmoid object or a 10 shop
jacked or raloo object and we just
combine these objects together chain
them into what ends up being a graph
which I refer to as a flow graph that
represents the computation done when you
do a forward pass in your neural network
up until you reach the output layer so I
mentioned it now because that's you'll
see you know the different software's
that we presented over a weekend will
essentially sort of you know exploit
some of that representation of the
computation and neural nets it also be
handy for computing gradients which I'll
talk about
in a few minutes and so that's how we
perform predictions in neural network so
we get an input we eventually reach an
output layer that gives us a
distribution over classes if we're
performing classification if I want to
actually classify I would just assign
the class corresponding to the unit that
has the highest activation that would
correspond to classifying into the class
that has the highest probability
according to the neural net and but then
you might ask the question okay what
kind of problems can we solve with
neural networks or more technically what
kind of functions can we represent
mapping from some input X into some
arbitrary output and so if you look at
if you go look at my videos I try to
give more intuition as to why we have
this result here but essentially if we
have a single hidden layer a neural
network it's been shown that with a
linear output we can approximate any
continuous function arbitrarily well as
long as we have enough hidden units so
that is there's a value for these biases
and these weights such that any
continuous function I can actually
represent it as well as I want I just
need to add enough hidden units so this
result applies if you use activation
functions nonlinear activation functions
like sigmoid and tan H so as I said in
my videos if you want a bit more
intuition as to why that would be you
can go check that out but that's a
really nice result it means that by
focusing on this family of machine
learning models that our neural networks
I can pretty much potentially represent
any kind of classification function
however this result does not tell us how
do we actually find the weights and the
bias values such that I can represent a
given function it doesn't essentially
tell us how do we train a neural network
and so that's what we'll discuss next
let's talk about that how do we actually
from a data set train a neural network
to perform good classification on for
that problem so what we'll typically do
is use a framework that's very generic
in machine learning known as empirical
risk minimization or structural risk
minimization if you're using
regularization so this framework
essentially transformed
a problem of learning as a problem of
optimizing so what we'll do is that will
first choose a loss function that I'm
noting as L and the last function it
compares the output of my model so the
output layer of my neural network with
the actual target
so I'm indexing with it exponent here
with T to essentially ask the index over
all my different examples in my training
set and so my loss function will tell me
is this output good or bad given that
the label is actually Y and well I'll do
I'll also define a regularizer so theta
here is you can think of it as it's just
the concatenation of all my biases and
all of my weights in my neural net so
those are all the parameters of my
neural network and the regularizer will
essentially penalize certain values of
these weights so as I'll talk more
specifically later on for instance you
might want to have your way to not be
too far from zero that's a frequent
intuition that we implement with
regularizer
and so the optimization problem that
we'll try to solve when learning is to
minimize the average loss of my neural
network over my training example so
summing over all training examples I
have capital T examples plus some weight
here that's known as the weight DK some
hyper parameter lambda times my regular
Iser so in other words I'm going to try
to have my loss on my training set as
small as possible over all the training
example and also try to satisfy my
regularizer as much as possible
and so now we have this optimization
problem and we learning will just
correspond to trying to solve this
problem so performing this finding this
argument here for over my weights and my
biases and if I want to do this I can
just invoke some optimization procedure
from the optimization community and the
one algorithm that you'll see constantly
in deep learning is stochastic gradient
descent this is the optimization
algorithm that will often use for
training neural networks so SGD
stochastic gradient descent
functions as follows you first
initialize all of your parameters that
is finding initial values for my weight
matrices and all of my bio C's and then
for a certain number of epochs so an
epoch will be a full pass over all my
examples that's what I'll call an epoch
so for a certain number of full
iterations over my training set
I'll draw each training example so I
pair X input X target Y and then I'll
compute what is the gradient of my loss
with respect to my parameters all of my
parameters all my weights and all my
biases this is what this notation here
so nabla for the gradient of the loss
function and here I'm indexing with
respect to which parameter I want the
gradient so I'm going to compute what is
the gradient of my last function with
respect to my parameters and plus lambda
times the gradient of my regularizer as
well and then I'm going to get a
direction in which I should move my
parameters since the greyman tells me
how to increase the loss I want to go in
the opposite direction and decrease it
so my direction will be the opposite so
that's why I have a minus here and so
this Delta is going to be the direction
in which I'll move my parameters by
taking a step and the step is just a
step size alpha which is often referred
to as a learning rate times my direction
which I just add to my current values of
my parameters my biases and my weights
and that's going to give me my new value
for all of my parameters and I iterate
like that over going over all pairs x
wise computing my gradient taking a
steps out in the opposite direction and
then doing that several times okay so
that's how stochastic gradient descent
works and that's essentially the
learning procedure it's represented by
this this procedure so in this algorithm
there are few things we need to specify
to be able to implement it and execute
it
we need a loss function the choice for
the loss function we need a procedure
that's efficient for computing the
gradient of the loss with respect to my
parameters we need to choose a
regularizer if you want one and we need
a way of initializing my parameters so
next what I'll do is
go through each of these these four
different things we need to choose
before actually being able to execute
the classic gradient descent so first
the last function so as I said we will
interpret the output layer as assigning
probabilities to each potential class in
which I can classify my input X well in
this case something that would be
natural is to try to maximize the
probability of the correct class the
actual class in which my example XT
belongs to I'd like to increase the
value of the probability assigned by
computed by my neural network and so
because we set up the problem in which
we have a loss that we minimize instead
of maximizing the probability what we'll
actually do is minimize the negative and
the actual log probability so the log
likelihood of assigning X to the correct
class Y so this is represented here so
given my output layer and the true label
Y my loss will be minus the log of the
probability of Y for minor according to
my neural net and that would be well
take my output layer and look at the
unit so index the unit corresponding to
the correct class so that's why I'm
indexing by Y here we take the log
because numerically it turns out to be
more stable we get nicer looking
gradients and sometimes in certain
software's you'll see instead of talking
about the negative log likelihood or log
probability you'll see it referred as
the cross entropy and that's because you
can think of this as performing a sum
over all possible classes and then for
each class checking well is this
potential class the target class so I
have an indicator function that is one
if Y is equal to C so if my iterator
Class C is actually equal to the real
class I'm going to multiply that by the
log of the probability actually assigned
to that class C and this this function
here so this expression here is like a
cross entropy between the empirical
distribution which assigns 0 probability
to all the other classes but a
probability of 1 to the correct class
and the actual distribution over
that my neural net is computing which is
f of X okay that's just a technical
detail you can just think about this
here I only mention it because in
certain libraries it's actually
mentioned as the cross-entropy a loss so
that's for the loss then we need also a
procedure for computing what is the
gradient of my loss with respect to all
of my parameters in my neural net so the
biases and the weights you can go look
at my videos if on the actual derivation
of all the details for all of these
different expressions I don't have time
for that so all I'll do and presumably a
lot of you I actually seen you know
these derivations if you haven't just go
check out the videos in any case I'm
going to go through what the algorithm
is I'm going to highlight some of the
key points that will come up later in
understanding out actually back
propagation functions so the basic idea
is that we'll compute gradients by
exploiting the chain rule and we'll go
from the top layer all the way to the
bottom
computing gradients for layers that are
closer and closer to the input as we go
and exploiting the chain rule to exploit
or reuse previous computations we've
made at upper layers to compute the
gradients at the layers of below so we
usually start by computing what is the
gradient at the output layer so what's
the gradient of my loss with respect to
my output layer it actually it's more
convenient to compute the loss with
respect to the pre activation it's
actually a very simple expression so
that that's why I have the gradient of
this vector a L plus 1 that's the pre
activation at the very last layer of the
loss function which is minus the log f
of XY and it turns out this gradient is
super simple it's minus II of Y so
that's the one Hut vector for class Y so
what this means is a of Y is just a
vector filled with a bunch of zeros and
then the one at the correct class so if
Y was the fourth class then in this case
it would be this vector we have a one at
the fourth dimension so e of Y is just a
vector it's we call it the one Hut
vector full of zeros and the single one
at the position corresponding to the
correct class so
this part of the grain is essentially
saying is that I'm going to increase I
want to increase the probability of the
correct class I want to increase the pre
activation which will increase the
probability of the correct class and I'm
going to subtract what is the current
probabilities assigned by my neural net
to all of the classes so f of X that's
my output layer and that's the current
beliefs of the neural net as to in which
class what's the probably of signing the
input to each class so what this is
doing is essentially trying to decrease
the probability of everything and
specifically decrease it as much as I
the neural net currently believes that
the input belongs to it and so if you
think about the subtraction of these two
things well for the class that's the
correct class I'm going to have one
minus some number between zero and one
because it's a probability so that's
going to be positive so I'm going to
increase the probability of the correct
class and for everything else it's going
to be zero minus a positive number so
it's going to be negative I'm actually
going to decrease the probability of
everything else so in two Li and it
makes sense this gradient has the right
behavior and I'm going to take that pre
activation gradient I'm going to
propagate it from the top to the bottom
and and essentially iterating from the
last layer which is the output layer l
plus 1 all the way down to the first
layer and as I'm going down I'm going to
compute the gradient with respect to my
parameters and then compute what's the
gradient for the pre activation that the
layer below and then iterate like that
so at each iteration of that loop I take
what is the current gradient of the loss
function with respect to the pre
activation at the current layer and I
can compute the gradient of the loss
function with respect to my weight
matrix so not doing the derivation here
it it's actually simply this vector so
my in my notation I assume that all the
vectors are column vectors so this pre
activation gradient vector and I
multiply it by the transpose of the
activations so the value of the layer
right below the layer K minus one so
because I take the transpose that's a
multiplication like this
you can see if I do the outer product
essentially between these two vectors
I'm going to get a matrix of the same
size as my weight matrix so it all
checks out
that makes sense it turns out that the
gradient of the loss with respect to the
bias is exactly the gradient of the loss
with respect to the pre activation so
that's very simple so that gives me now
my gradients for my parameters and now I
need to compute okay what is going to be
the gradient of the pre activations at
the layer below
well first I'm going to get the gradient
of the last function with respect to the
activation at the layer below well
that's just taking my pre activation
gradient vector and multiplying it by
for some reason does it show here but
and multiplied by the transpose of my
weight matrix super simple operation
just a linear transformation of my
gradients at layer cake linear and
transform to get my gradients of the
activation at the layer K minus one and
then to get the gradients of the pre
activation so before the activation
function
I mean to I'm gonna take this gradient
here which is the gradient of the
activation function at the layer K minus
one and then I applied the gradient
corresponding to the partial derivative
of my nonlinear activation function so
this here this refers to an element-wise
product so I'm taking these two vectors
this vector here in this vector here I'm
going to do an element-wise product
between the two and this vector here is
just a partial derivative of the
activation function for each unit
individually that I've put together into
a vector okay this is what this
corresponds to now the key things to
notice is first that this path computing
all the gradients and doing all these
iterations is actually fairly cheap its
complexity is essentially the same as
the one is doing a forward pass so all
I'm doing are linear transformations
multiplying by matrices in this case the
transpose of my weight matrix and then
I'm also doing this sort of nonlinear
operation where I'm multiplying by the
gradient of the activation function
that's the first thing to notice and the
second thing to notice is that here I'm
doing this element-wise product so if
any of these terms here for a unit is
very close to zero then the pre
activation gradient is going to be zero
for the next layer and I highlight this
point because essentially whenever
that's something to think about a lot
when you're training neural nets
whenever this gradient here these
partial derivatives come close to zero
that it means the grain will not
propagate well to the next layer which
means that you're not going to get a
good gradient to update your parameters
now when does that happen when will you
see these terms here being close to zero
well that's going to be when the partial
derivatives of these nonlinear
activation functions are close to zero
or zero so we can look at the partial
derivative say of the sigmoid function
it turns out it's super easy to compute
it's just the Sigma itself times 1 minus
the sigmoid itself so that means that
whenever the activation of the unit for
sigmoid unit is close to 1 or close to 0
I essentially get a partial there that's
close to zero you can kind of see it
here the slope here is essentially flat
and the slope here is flat that's the
value of the partial derivative so in
other words if my pre activations are
very negative or very positive so if my
unit is very saturated then gradients
will have a hard time propagating to the
next layer that's the key inside here
same thing for the tension so the turns
out the partial derivative is also easy
to compute you just take the tangible
you square it and going to subtract it
to 1 and yeah indeed if it's close to
minus 1 or close to 1 you can see that
the slope is flat so again if the unit
is saturating gradients will propagate I
have a hard time propagating to the next
layer and for the relu the rectified
linear activation function the gradient
is even simpler it's you just check
whether the pre activation is greater
than 0 if it is the partial derivative
is 1 if it's not at 0 so actually either
we're going to multiply by 1 or 0 you
essentially get a binary mask when
you're performing the propagation
through their value and you can see it
the the slope here is flat and otherwise
you have a linear function so actually
here at the shrinking of the grade and
toward 0 is
even harder it's exactly multiplying by
zero if your have a unit that's
saturating below and beyond all the math
in terms of actually using those in
practice during the weekend you'll see
three different libraries that
essentially allows you to compute these
gradients for you you actually usually
don't write down backdrop you just use
all of these modules that you've
implemented and it turns out there's a
way of automatic automatic ly
differentiating your loss function and
getting gradients for free in terms of
effort in terms of programming effort
with respect to your parameters so
conceptually the way you do this and you
see essentially three different
libraries doing it in slightly different
ways what you do is you up meant your
flow graph by adding at the very end the
computation of your loss function and
then each of these boxes which are
conceptually objects that are taking
arguments and computing a value you're
going to augment them to also have a
method that's a backdrop or B prop
method you'll often see actually this
expression being used be prop and what
this method should do is that it should
take as input what is the gradient of
the loss with respect to myself and then
it should propagate to its arguments so
the things that its parents in the flow
graph the things that takes to compute
its own value it's going to propagate
them using the chain rule what is their
gradients with respect to the loss so
what this means is that you would sort
of start the process by initializing
well the gradient of the loss with
respect to itself is 1 and then you pass
the B prop method here 1 and then it's
going to propagate to its argument what
is by using the chain rule what is the
gradient of the loss with respect to f
of X and then you're going to call B
prop on this object here and it's going
to compute well add the gradient of the
loss with respect to myself f of X from
this I can compute what's the gradient
of my argument which is the pre
activation at layer 2 which is back to
the loss so I'm going to reuse the
computation I just got and update it
using my what is essentially the
Jacobian and then I'm going to take the
pre activation here which now knows what
is the gradient of the loss with respect
to itself
activation it's going to propagate to
the weights and the biases and the layer
below update them with informing them of
what is the grain into the last with
respect to themselves and you continue
like this essentially going through the
flow graph but in the opposite direction
so the library torch the basic library
torch essentially functions like this
quite explicitly it you construct you
chain these elements together and then
when you're performing back propagation
you're going in the reverse order of
these chained elements and then you have
libraries like torch other grand piano
and tens of which you learn about which
are doing things slightly more
sophisticated there and you'll learn
about that later on okay so that's the
discussion of how you actually compute
gradients of the last with respect to
the parameters so that's another
component we need in stochastic grain in
this end we can choose a regular Weiser
one that's often used is the l2
regularization so that's just the sum of
the squared of the all the weights and
the gradient of that is just twice times
the weight so it's a super simple
gradient to compute we usually don't
regularize the biases
there's no particularly important reason
for that it's just it there much for
your by see so it seems less important
and often this l2 regularization is
often referred to as weight DK so if you
hear about weight decayed that often
refers to l2 regularization and then
finally and this is also a very
important point you have to initialize
the parameters before you actually start
doing back prop and there are a few
tricky cases you need to make sure that
you don't fall into so the biases often
we initialize them to 0 there are
certain exceptions but for the most part
we initialize them to 0 but for the
weights there are a few things we can't
do so we can't initialize the weights to
0 and especially if you have 10 H
activations the reason and I won't
explain it here but it's not a bad
exercise to try to figure out why is
that essentially when you do your first
pass you're going to get gradients for
all your parameters that are going to be
0 so I'm going to be stuck at this 0
initialization so we can do that we
can't initialize all the weights to
exactly the same value if again you
think about it a little bit what's going
to happen is essentially that all the
weights coming into a unit within the
layer are going to have exactly the same
gradients which means they're going to
be updated exactly the same way which
means they're going to stay constant the
same that comes them but they're going
to stay the same the whole time so it's
as if you have multiple copies of the
same unit so you essentially have to
break that initial symmetry that you
would create if you initialize
everything to the same value so we end
up doing most of the time is initialized
the weights to some randomly generated
value often we generate them there are
few other recipes but one of them is to
initialize them from some uniform
distribution between lower and upper
bound this is a recipe here that is
often used that has some theoretical
grounding that's was derived
specifically for the 10h there's this
pepper paper here by exactly Goho and
yoshua bengio you can check out for some
intuition as to oh you know how you
should initialize the weights but
essentially this should be initially
random and this should be initially
close to zero random to break symmetry
and close to zero so that initially the
units are not already saturated because
if the units are saturated then there
are no gradients that are going to pass
through the units you essentially going
to get gradients very close to zero at
the lower layers so that's the main
intuitions they have weights that are
small and close to zero small and random
okay so those are the pieces we need for
running stochastic gradient descent so
that allows us to take a training set
and run the certain number of epochs and
app the neural nets learn from that
training set now there are other
quantities in our neural network that we
haven't specified out to choose them so
those are the hyper parameters so
usually we can have a separate
validation set most people here are
familiar with machine learning so that's
a typical procedure and then we need to
select things like ok how many layers do
I want how many units per layer do I
want what's the step size the learning
rate of my stochastic gradient descent
procedure that alpha number what is the
weight decay that I'm going to use so a
standard thing in machine learning is to
perform
a grid search that is if I have to our
parameters I list out a bunch of values
I want to try so for the number of
hidden units maybe I want to try a
hundred a thousand and two thousand say
and then for the learning rate maybe I
want to try 0.01 and 0.001 so a grid
search would just try all combinations
of these three values for their hidden
units and these two values for the
learning rates so that means that the
more I providers there are it's the
number of configurations you have to try
out blows up and grows exponentially so
another procedure that is now more more
common which is more practical is to
perform a form of random search in this
case what you do is for each parameter
you actually determine a distribution of
likely values you'd like to try so it
could be so for the number of hidden
units maybe I do a uniform distribution
over all integers from a hundred to a
thousand say or maybe a log uniform
distribution and for the learning rate
may be again the log uniform
distribution but from 0.001 to 0.01 say
and then to get an experiment to get
values for my hyper parameters to do an
experiment with and get a performance of
my validation set I just independently
sample from these distributions for each
hyper parameter to get a full
configuration for my experiment and then
because I have this way of getting one
experiment I do it independently for all
of my jobs all of my experiment that I
will do so in this case if I know I have
like enough compute power to do 50
experiments I just sample 15 dependent
samples from these distributions for
parameters perform these 50 experiments
and I just take the best one what's nice
about it is that there are no unlike
grid search there are never any holes in
the grid that is you just specify how
many experiments you do if one of your
jobs died well you just have one less
but there's no hole in your experiment
and also one reason why it's
particularly useful this approach is
that if you have a specific value in
grid search for one of the hyper
parameters that just makes the
experiment not work at all so learning
rates are a lot like this if you have a
learning rate that's too high it's quite
possible that convergence of the
optimization will not converge well if
you're using a grid search it means that
for all the experiments that use that
specific value of the learning rate
they're all going to be garbage they're
all not going to be useful and you don't
really get this sort of big waste of
computation if you do random search
because most likely all the values of
your hyperparameters are going to be
unique because their sample say from a
uniform distribution over some some
range so that actually works quite well
and and and quite recommended and there
are more advanced methods like methods
based on machine learning bayesian
optimization and or sometimes known as
sequential model based optimization that
I won't talk about but that works a bit
better than random search and and that's
another alternative if you think you
have an issue finding good hyper
parameters is to investigate some of
these more advanced methods now you do
this for most of your hyper parameters
but for the number of epochs the number
of times you go through all of your
examples in your training set what we
usually do is not grid search or random
search but we use a thing known as early
stopping the idea here is that if I've
trained a neural net for 10 epochs while
training a neural net with all the other
hyper parameters kept constant but one
more epoch is easy I just do one more
epoch so I shouldn't try to I shouldn't
start over and then do say eleven epochs
from scratch and so what we would do is
we would just track what is the
performance on the validation set as I
do more and more epochs and what we will
typically see is the training error will
go down but the validation set
performance will go down and eventually
go up the intuition here is that the gap
between the performance on the training
set and the performance on the
validation set will tend to increase and
since the training curve cannot go below
usually some bound then eventually the
validation set performance has to go up
sometimes it won't sell go up oh is sort
of stay stable so with early stopping
what we do is that if we reach a point
where the validation set performance
hasn't improved from some certain number
of iterations which we refer to as the
look-ahead
we just stop we go back to the neural
net that had the best performance
overall in the validation set and that's
my neural network so I have now a very
cheap way of actually getting the number
of iterations or the number of epochs
over my training set a few more tricks
of the trade so it's always useful to
normalize your data it will often have
the effect of speeding up training if
you have real valued data for binary
data that usually keep it as it is so
what I mean by that is just subtract for
each dimension what is the average in
the training set of that dimension and
then dividing by the standard deviation
of each dimension again in my input
space so this can speed up training we
often use a decay on the learning rate
there are a few methods for doing this
one that's very simple is to start with
a large learning rate and then track the
performance on the validation set and
once on the validation set it stops
improving you decrease your learning
rate by some ratio maybe you're divided
by two and then you continue training
for some time hopefully the validation
set performance starts improving and
then at some point it stops improving
and then you stop or you divide again by
two so that sort of gives you an
adaptive using the validation set an
adaptive way of changing your learning
rate and that can again work better than
having a very small learning rate than
waiting for a long time so making very
fast progress initially and then slower
progress towards TM also I've described
so far the approach for training neural
nets that is based on a single example
at a time but in practice we actually
use what's called mini batches that is
we compute the last function on the
small subset of example say 64 128 and
then we take the average of the loss of
all these examples in that mini batch
and that's actually we compute the
gradient of this average loss on that
mini batch the reason why we do this is
that it turns out that you can very
efficiently implement the forward pass
over all of these 64 128 examples in my
mini batch in one pass by instead of
doing vector matrix multiplications when
we come
the pre activations doing matrix matrix
multiplications which are faster than
doing multiple matrix vector
multiplications so in your code often
there will be this other hyper parameter
which is mostly optimized for speed in
terms of how quickly training will
proceed of the number of examples in
your mini batch other things to improve
optimization might be using a thing like
momentum that is instead of using as the
descent direction the gradient of your
last function I'm actually going to
track a descent direction which I'm
going to compute as the current gradient
for my current example or mini-batch
plus some fraction of the previous
update the previous direction of update
and better now is a hyper parameter you
have to optimize so what this does is if
all the update directions agree oh
across multiple updates then it will
start picking up momentum and actually
make bigger steps in those directions
and there are multiple even more
advanced methods for adding adaptive
types of learning rates I mentioned them
here very quickly because you might see
them in papers there's a method known as
a de grab where the learning rate is
actually scaled for each descent for
each dimension so for each weight and
each by seize it's going to be scaled by
what is the square root of the
cumulative sum of the squared gradients
so what I track is I take my gradient
vector at each step I do an element-wise
square of all the dimensions on my
gradients my gradient vector and then I
accumulate that in some variables that
I'm noting as gamma here and then for my
descent direction I take the gradient
and I do an element-wise division by the
square root of this cumulative sum of
squared gradients
there's also rmsprop which is
essentially like a de grab but instead
of doing a cumulative stuff a sum we're
going to do an exponential moving
average so we take the previous value x
sub factor plus one minus this factor
times the current squared gradient so
that's rmsprop and then there's adam
which is essentially a combination of
rmsprop with momentum which is more
involved and i won't have time to
describe it here but that's
method that's often you know actually
implemented in these different softwares
and that people seem to use with a lot
of success and finally in terms of
actually debugging your implementations
so for instance if you're lucky you can
build your neural network without
difficulty using the current tools that
are available in torch or 10 to Flora
Theano
but maybe sometimes you actually have to
implement certain gradients for a new
module and a new box in your flow graph
that isn't currently supported if you do
this you should check that you've
implemented your gradients correctly and
one way of doing that is to actually
compare the gradients computed by your
code with a finite difference of
estimate so what you do is for each
parameter you add some very small
epsilon value say 10 to the minus 6 and
you compute what is the output of your
module and then you subtract the same
thing but where you've subtracted the
small quantity and then the divide by 2
epsilon so if epsilon is converges to
zero then you actually get the partial
derivative but if it's small it's going
to be an approximate and usually this
finite difference estimate will be very
close to a correct implementation of the
real gradient so you should definitely
do that if you actually implemented some
of the gradients in your code and in
another useful thing to do is to
actually do a very small experiment on
the small data set before you actually
run your full experiment on your
complete data set so you say 50 examples
so just taking a random subset of 50
examples from your your data set
actually just make sure that your code
can over fit to that data can
essentially classify it perfectly given
you know enough capacity that you would
think it should get it so if it's not
the case then there's a few things that
you might want to investigate maybe your
initialization is such that the units
are already saturated initially and so
there's no actual optimization happening
because some of the gradients on some of
the weights are exactly zero so you
might want to check your initialization
maybe your gradients are just you know
you're using a model you implemented
gradients for and maybe there are
gradients are not properly implemented
maybe you haven't normalized your input
which creates some instability
making it harder for stochastic gradient
descent to work successfully maybe your
learning rate is too large then you
should consider trying smaller learning
rates that's actually a pretty good way
of having a some idea of the magnitude
of the learning rate you should be using
and and then once you actually over fit
in your small trainings that you're
ready to do a full experiment on on a
larger data set that said this is not a
replacement for gradient checking so
backdrop is and stochastic gradient
descent it's a great algorithm that's
very bug resistant you will pretend
potentially see some learning happening
even if some of your gradients are wrong
or say exactly zero so you should that's
great you know if you're an engineer and
you're implementing things spun would
code is somewhat bug resistant but if
you're actually doing science and try to
understand what's going on that's that
can be a complication so do do both
gradient checking and a small experiment
like that all right and so for the last
few minutes I'll actually try to
motivate what you'll be learning quite a
bit about in the next two days that is
the specific case for deep learning so
I've already told you that if I have a
neural net win enough hidden units
theoretically I can potentially
represent pretty much any function any
classification function so why would I
want multiple layers so there are a few
motivations behind this the first one is
taken directly from our own brains so we
know in the visual cortex that the light
that hits our retina eventually goes
through several regions in the visual
cortex eventually reaching narrow known
as v1 when you have units that are or
neurons that are essentially tuned to
small forms like edges and then it goes
on to v4 where it's likely more complex
patterns that the units are tuned for
and then you reach AIT where you
actually have neurons are specific to
certain objects or certain units and so
the idea here is that perhaps that's
also what we want another artificial say
you know vision system we'd like it if
it's detecting faces to have a first
layer that detects simple edges and then
another layer that perhaps puts these
edges together detecting slightly more
complex things
nose or mouth or eyes and then
eventually have a layer that combines
these slightly less abstract or more
abstract units to get something even
more abstract like a complete phase
there's also some theoretical
justification for doing using multiple
layers so the early results were mostly
based on studying boolean functions or a
function that takes as input can think
of it as a vector of just zeros and ones
and you could show that there are
certain functions that if you add the
essentially a boolean neural network or
essentially a boolean circuit and you
restricted the number of layers of that
circuit that there are certain functions
that in this case to represent certain
boolean functions exactly you would need
an exponential number of units in each
of these layers whereas if you allowed
yourself to have multiple layers then
you could represent these functions more
compactly and so there's that's another
motivation that perhaps with more layers
we can represent fairly complex
functions in a more compact way and then
there's the reason that they just work
so we've seen in the past few years
great success in speech recognition
where it's essentially revolutionized
the field where everyone's using deep
learning for speech recognition and same
thing for visual object recognition
where again deep learning is sort of the
method of choice for identifying objects
and images so then why are we doing this
only recently why didn't we do deep
learning
way back when back prop was invented
which is essentially in 1980s and even
before that so it turns out training
deep neural networks is actually not
that easy there are few hurdles that one
can be confronted with I've already
mentioned one of the issue which is that
some of the gradients might be fading as
you go from the top layer to the bottom
layer because we keep multiplying by the
derivative of the activation function so
that makes training hard it could be
that the lower layers at very small
gradients are barely moving and
exploring the space of correct you know
features to learn for a given problem so
that sometimes that's the problem you
find you have a hard time just fitting
your data and you're essentially
underfitting
or it could be that with you know deeper
neural nets Oh bigger neural nets we
have more parameters so perhaps
sometimes actually overfitting we're in
a situation where all the functions that
we can represent with the same neural
net represented by this gray area
function actually includes yes the right
function but it's so large that for a
finite training set the odds that I'm
going to find the one that's close to
the true classifying function the real
system that like to have is going to be
very different so in this case I mean
I'm essentially overfitting and that
might also be a situation we're in and
unfortunately there's never there are
many situations where one problem is
observed over fitting or under fitting
and so we essentially have you know in
the field develop tools for finding both
situations and I'm going to rapidly
touch a few of those which you will see
will come up later on in multiple talks
so one of the first hypothesis which
might be that you're under fitting well
you can essentially just fight this by
waiting longer so training longer if you
have your grayness are too small and
this is essentially why you're
progressing very slowly when you're
training well if you're using GPUs and
are able to do more iterations over the
same training set within less time that
might just you know solve your problem
of underfitting and I think we've seen
some of that and this is partly why GPUs
have been so game-changing for deep
learning or you can use just better
optimization methods also and if you're
overfitting well we just need better
regularization i've been involved early
on in my PhD on using unsupervised
learning as a way to regularize neural
nets if I have time I'll talk a little
bit about that then there's another
method you might have learned heard
about known as dropout so I'll try to
touch at least two methods that are
essentially trying to address some of
these issues so the first one that I'll
talk about this dropout it's actually
very easy very simple so the idea of if
our neural net is essentially
overfitting so it's too good at training
on the training set well we're
essentially going to [ __ ] training
when I make it harder to fit the
training set and where we're going to do
that and dropout is that we will
stochastically remove hidden units
independently so for each hidden unit
before we do a forward pass we'll flip a
coin and we'd probably have we will
multiply the activation by zero with
probability 1/2 we'll multiply it by 1
so what this means is that if a unit is
multiplied by 0 it's effectively not in
the neural net anymore and we're doing
this independently for each hidden units
so that means that in a layer a unit
cannot rely anymore on the presence on
any other units to try to sort of
synchronize and adapt to perform a
complex classification or learn a
complex feature and that was partly the
motivation behind dropout is that this
procedure might encourage types of
features that are not co-adapted and are
less likely to overfit so we often use
0.5 as the probability of dropping out a
unit it turns out it often surprisingly
is the best value but that's another
hyper parameter you might want to tune
and in terms of how it impacts an
implementation of back prop it's it's
very simple so the forward pass before I
do it I just sample my binary masks for
all my layers and and then when I'm
performing back drop well my gradient on
the oh sorry so that's the Ford pass
yeah I'm just multiplying by this binary
mask here so super simple change and
then in terms of back prop well I'm also
going to multiply by the mask when I get
my gradient on the pre activation and
also you know don't forget that the
activations are now different they
actually include the masks in in my
notation it's a very simple change the
forward and backward pass when you're
training and also another thing that I
shouldn't emphasize is that the mask is
being resampled for every example so
before you do a forward pass you
resample the mask you don't keep it you
know sample at once and then use it the
whole time and then that test time
because we don't really like a model
that sort of randomly changes its output
because it will if we stochastically
change the masks what we do is we
replace the mask by the probability of
dropping out a unit so actually of
keeping a unit so if we
0.5 that's just 0.5 we can actually show
that if you have a neural net with a
single hidden layer doing this
transformation at test time multiplying
by 0.5 is equivalent to doing a
geometric average of all the possible
neural networks with all the different
binary mask patterns so it's essentially
one way of thinking about drop out in
the single layer case is that it's kind
of an in sembly method we have a lot of
models an exponential number of models
which are all sharing the same weights
but have different masks that intuition
though doesn't transfer for deep neural
nets in the sense that you cannot show
this result it really only applies to a
single neural networks in gold hidden
layer so in practice it's very effective
but do expect some slowdown in training
so often we tend to see that training or
network to completion will take twice as
many epochs if you're using dropout with
0.5 and here you have the reference if
you want to learn more about different
variations of dropouts and so on and
I'll and I'll probably won't talk about
the unsupervised retraining for lack of
time but I'll talk about another thing
that you'll definitely probably hear
about and that's implementing these
different packages which is Bachelor
organization Bachelor ization is kind of
interesting in the sense that it's been
shown to better optimize that is certain
networks that would otherwise under fit
would not under fit as much anymore fuse
Bachelor ization
but also it's been shown that when you
use batch normalization dropout is not
as useful and drop out being a
regularization method that suggests that
perhaps patch normalization is also
regularizing in some way so these things
are not you know one or the other
they're not mutually exclusive you can
have a regularizer that also turns out
helps you better optimize so the
intuition behind batch normalization is
you know much like I've suggested that
normalizing your inputs actually can
help speeding up training well how about
we also normalize all the hidden layers
when I'm doing my forward pass so now
the problem in doing this is that I can
compute the mean and the standard
deviations of my inputs once and for all
because they're constant but my hidden
layers are constantly changing because
I'm training these parameters
so the mean and the standard deviation
of my units will change and so I it
would be very expensive if every time I
did an update of my parameters I
recomputed the means and the standard
deviations of all of my units so
bachelors ation addresses some of these
issues as follows so the way works is
first batch the normalization is going
to be applied on actually the pre
activation so not the activation of the
unit but before the non-linearity during
training to address the issue that we
don't want to compute means over the
full training set because that would be
too slow I'm actually going to compute
it on each mini batch so I have to do
mini batch training here I'm going to
take my small mini batch of 64 128
examples and that's the set of examples
on which I'm going to compute my means
and standard deviations and then when I
do back prop I'm actually going to take
into account the normalization so now
there's going to be a gradient going
through the computation of the mean and
the standard deviation because they
depend on the parameters of the neural
network and then that test time we'll
just use the global mean and global
standard deviation once I finished
training I can actually do a full pass
over the whole training set and got all
of my means and standard deviations so
that's the essentially the pseudocode
for that taken out of the paper directly
so if X is a pre activation for a unit
and have multiple pre activations for a
single unit across my mini batch I would
compute what is the average for that
unit pre activation across my examples
in my mini batch compute my variance and
then subtract the mean and divide by the
square root of the variance plus some
epsilon for numerical stability in case
the variance is too close to zero and
then another thing is that actually
batch normalization doesn't just perform
this normalization and outputs the
normalize pre activation it then
actually performs a linear
transformation on it so it multiplies it
by this parameter gamma which is going
to be trained by gradient descent and
it's often called a gain parameter of
batchelomez ation and it adds a bias
better and the reason is that if I'm
subtracting by the mean then each of
these you
have the biased parameter so if I
subtracted then this essentially here
there's no bias anymore it was present
here was present here and now it's been
subtracted to have to add the bias but
after the bachelor ization essentially
so these betters here are essentially
the new bias parameters and those will
actually be trained so we do gradient
descent also on those so bachelor
ization adds a few parameters all right
and I as I said I'm just gonna skip over
this and you know I'm not showing what
the gradients are when your backdrop
through the mean and so on it's
describing the paper for Necedah
gradients but otherwise in the different
packages you actually have access to
you'll get the gradients automatically
it's usually been implemented skipping
over that I'll just finish if you
actually want to learn about
unsupervised retraining and why it works
videos on that so you can check that out
and I guess that's it thank you
thanks you go so we have a few minutes
for questions which are intermingled
with a break so feel free to I your go
for our break or ask questions to Google
I believe there are microphones and I'll
also stick around so if you want to ask
your questions offline that's also fine
if you want ask questions you can go to
the mic
go to the microphone hi I mentioned the
rail ooh adds varsity can you explain
why yeah so um so the first thing is
that it's observed in practice and they
add some sparse some sparsity in part
because you have the non-linearity at
zero below so it means that units are
going to be exactly potentially exactly
sparse exactly essentially absent of the
hidden layer the real there are a few
reasons to sort of explain why you get
sparsity it turns out that this process
of doing a linear transformation
followed by the value activation
function is very close to some of the
steps you would do when you're
optimizing for sparse codes in the
sparse coding model if you know about
sparse coding so they're like
essentially in optimization methods that
given some sparse coding model we'll
find what is the sparse representation
hidden representation for some input and
it's mostly a sequence of linear
transformations followed by this sort of
like relu like activation function and I
think this is partly the explanation
otherwise I don't I don't know a like
solid you know explanation for why that
is beyond you know it's observed in
practice more questions if not let's
thank you again and we are we reconvene
in ten minutes